drew barrymore and kanye reeves go way
back as they were called starring in the
1986 film babes in toyland if you guys
have seen this let me know i've never
heard of this movie before i haven't
yeah right now during candy's recent
appearance on the drew barrymore show
they talked about that
yeah and drew recalled a particularly
memorable moment that one time keanu
took her on a wild joy ride on his
motorcycle on her 16th birthday take a
look can i take it back to a memory that
i have with you
i was at this club and it was my 16th
birthday and you came in
this is the memory i have of it if you
have anything to add or change
please let me know and you walked in
and you grabbed my hand
and you took me outside
and you put me on your motorcycle oh my
and we drove at the warp speed of my
life
we went and you took me on the ride of
my life and i was so free i was such a
free human being
and it was just this moment where i just
remember loving life
and being so happy
and i hold it so dear because the older
we get the harder it is to get to that
feeling yeah
yeah
um i wonder where we're at took you
where was which where which clubhour i
believe it was on third street in los in
los angeles okay and and then i think we
definitely took off down third and then
we drove around for a while and then we
went back and i went back in and i don't
remember if you came in or not i
literally walked back into the party
like skipping
like
i mean
i didn't even think of it as a sweet 16
but i'm now realizing it you can't have
a better sweet 16 than
being put on your motorcycle and having
the moment where you understand what
freedom is
wow if we were on third i must okay
oh wow we we probably went fast so yeah
so fast
like irresponsibly fast